[Aplausos]
[Música]
bienvenidos un día más a diario de copas
el programa de france 24 en el que
analizamos la actualidad de la eurocopa
y la copa américa vamos con los
titulares
italia venció él convenció ante su vice
se convirtió en la primera selección de
la eurocopa clasificada a octavos de
final analizamos el rendimiento de la
azzurra y su buen juego en el torneo
ucrania le ganó a macedonia del norte y
aprieta la pelea por la clasificación en
el grupo se países bajos y austria
definen hoy quién será el líder de un
grupo en el que no faltan los goles
regresa a la copa américa brasil semilla
perú y colombia se enfrenta a venezuela
analizamos las rotaciones de los equipos
de tite y reinaldo rueda
y tal es el primer equipo clasificado a
los octavos de final de la eurocopa y
vamos a hablar del rendimiento de la
azzurra para ello quiero darle la
bienvenida un día más a sara castro
directores del diario de colombia hola
juan buenas tardes un gusto estar con
ustedes una jornada de mucho fútbol y sí
como lo dices italia no solo primer
clasificado octavos sino que creo que es
el mejor equipo que hemos visto en el
torneo en cada jugada se ve el trabajo
de roberto mancini trabajo roberto
mancini además con muchos jugadores que
juegan de una manera colectiva
ayer miércoles italia precisamente se
impuso a sisa suiza por 3 a 0 en otro
buen partido en el olímpico de roma en
el grupo a
por su parte de gales ganó y dejó contra
las cuerdas a turquía dos victorias de
dos para los italianos y con seis goles
a favor
sarah que es lo que hace entonces
diferente a ese italia que juega también
para mí es la determinación individual y
colectiva es decir cada uno de los
jugadores no sólo confía en sus
condiciones sino que también confía en
que el lugar del campo va a estar
posicionado su compañero y esto habla de
unas condiciones muy importantes para
ganar mentalidad
y va intensidad y sobre todo
coordinación estamos hablando de un
equipo que además tiene registros
diferentes cuando hablamos de registros
diferentes en el fútbol es que no ataca
de una sola manera y no defiende una
sola manera aprovecha los espacios tiene
uno contra uno se repliega bien y
presiona bien esto es lo que hemos visto
en una italia que sin duda ha
sorprendido a todo el mundo del fútbol
nosotros tenemos un poco en debate
porque para mí yo digo que italia no es
una favorita porque porque tiene
jugadores de muchísima calidad como
donnarumma berardi locatelli son
jugadores a los que les falta
consagrarse con un gran título nacional
o una final europea que crees que eso
les pueda costar en un momento decisivo
en esa eurocopa yo creo que igual si
bien no son grandes figuras y son
jugadores de jerarquía y lo que
necesitaba italia era recuperar una
identidad una manera de jugar y mancini
que había sido cuestionado en otras
oportunidades por su manera de entrenar
los equipos en esta ha logrado plasmar
mucho de lo que él fue como jugador y
estos jugadores están convencidos de esa
idea para mí eso es clave y creo que el
colectivo puede primar en un torneo como
éste también de momento de lo que está
haciendo
recibe lo que habíamos precisamente lo
que dijo el seleccionador roberto
mancini
comparando italia con otras elecciones
la encuesta europeo será franch a
francia es la campeona del mundo
portugal es la campeona de europa
bélgica ha estado en la cabeza del
ranking desde hace mucho una capilla del
mundo una campeona de europa una primera
en qingdao son equipos construidos hace
ya mucho antes que el nuestro es normal
que estén por delante de nosotros pero
en el fútbol todo puede pasar en moto
brady
para sanz anormales y ahora movió avante
en el fútbol todo puede pasar dice
roberto mancini un poco reconociendo
también que ellos está por debajo del
escalón de favoritos
sí pero pero el confianza trabajo yo
creo que él no quiere poner la
expectativa muy alta pero confía y sobre
todo en lo que está bien así es vamos a
analizar ahora los partidos de este
jueves tenemos 13 encuentros uno de
ellos está en juego por el grupo b
dinamarca se enfrenta a bélgica una de
las favoritas minutos 56 de partido
acaba de empatar bélgica con un gol deja
estar el hermano no de eden uno a uno en
este encuentro marcado como no por ese
homenaje de minutos
christian eriksen que se recupera
después de ese desvanecimiento en la
jornada inaugural lo decíamos vamos a
analizar el grupo c ucrania ganó a
macedonia del norte y tenemos a tres
equipos así con tres puntos porque
países bajos y austria juegan más
adelante y ahí puede salir el líder de
este grupo se une un grupo muy
interesante ucrania ya había mostrado
entre países bajos de lo que era capaz
es un equipo que tiene unas salidas muy
interesantes que hacen muy bien las
transiciones un equipo también muy bien
trabajado porque tengo un ídolo
ucraniano malinovski hemos hablado de
los jugadores que está poniendo atalanta
en cada una de las selecciones el equipo
de gasperini aparece con jugadores que
son muy inteligentes en el campo de
juego y vimos también un macedonia que
intentó pelear que en el segundo tiempo
le complicó las cosas a ucrania pero
ahora vamos a ver a los que definen al
líder de este grupo países bajos y
austria muy importante también la
decisión que ya tomó la uefa se
posicionó contra el racismo y
sancionando arnautovic él tuvo unas
declaraciones racistas en el partido
anterior y ahí la uefa fue implacable
él pidió disculpas pero no fue
suficiente en cuanto a países bajos hay
que decir que si bien frank de boer
había sido cuestionado por el estilo por
el sistema que estaba utilizando creo
que en el primer partido desde el juego
respondió esas inquietudes y hoy vamos a
ver un partido interesante lo deseamos
en titulares es el único grupo si no me
equivoco en el que todos los equipos han
marcado goles y han recibido goles
siempre este tipo de torneos hay un
grupo que nos espera y termina haciendo
como un poco el más emocionante sí igual
pero en general creo que hemos visto un
torneo con muy poca especulación todos
los equipos han salido a buscar con
diferentes maneras diferentes estilos
pero creo que en general esta eurocopa
lo que ha demostrado es que hay un alto
nivel y sobre todo esa búsqueda del
resultado constante así es una eurocopa
que casi siempre nos deja mucha igualdad
es el nivel que tenemos por lo general
en este torneo del viejo continente
vamos a pasar ahora a hablar de la copa
américa porque vuelve la actividad al
torneo a las 4 de la tarde hora de
bogotá a lima y quito colombia se
enfrenta a venezuela ya las 7 también
ahora de bogotá le may quito brasil se
mide a perú los técnicos de colombia y
de veras
reina reinaldo rueda y ti te van a
realizar unas rotaciones en el caso de
brasil estamos hablando que se espera
que haya hasta siete jugadores nuevos
sara porque los seleccionadores hacen
tantas rotaciones cuando a priori uno
podría pensar que jugadores intocables
en algunas posiciones a quien diaria de
copas le hemos hablado como de dos
conceptos que es probar jugadores y
variantes de juego pero también en este
punto entre algo muy interesante que
explicaba ayer reinaldo rueda y es la
biomédica y el rendimiento futbolístico
del jugador que es lo que se hace tener
jugadores en alta competencia durante un
torneo largo darles la oportunidad de
estar en nivel competitivo y creo que
eso va a ser muy interesante como decía
siete variantes ederson iría al arco
reemplazando a allison thiago silva
volvería en lugar de marquinhos fabinho
reemplazaría casemiro y gabi gol
reemplazaría richarlyson es decir
estamos viendo que todas las variantes
que tiene ti te las pone las pondría hoy
al servicio de ese colectivo y sobre
todo eso de tener muy activo un plantel
en un torneo que va a ser largo y
también teniendo en cuenta que pasan
cuatro del grupo lo repetiremos todos
los días porque sin duda esto condiciona
la competencia
y además un turno en el que estamos
viendo estas pausas entonces lo que
estamos viendo por parte de los
seleccionadores es no quiero que estas
pausas de dos días que no tenemos de
partidos afecte el rendimiento de toda
la plantilla al tener solamente a once
jugadores a la vez también juega a perú
en el caso del combinado de enka se
esperan novedades en el ataco no va a
santiago ormeño hay dudas sobre cristian
cueva y vamos a ver aún la padula que va
a ser ahora el referente del ataque con
la ausencia de paulo guerrero
bueno aquí hay que hablar de cristian
creo que ya empieza éstos son los
imponderables del fútbol sudamericano se
le acusa de haber incumplido los
protocolos en una reunión social
entonces esto también juega para los
entrenadores no el manejo al interior de
sus de su grupo y de cómo gestiona este
tipo de casos creo que perú tiene
complicaciones porque la no presencia de
vincula se le suma la de trabuco que son
los dos laterales que siempre en busca
buscan el juego ofensivo así que vamos a
ver cómo responde la padula en un equipo
que sin duda va a funcionar diferente
ricardo gareca tiene la presión lo hemos
hablado bien en el eliminatoria
complicada así que vamos a ver qué le
propone hoy
el gran favorito como es brasil lo que
decía y en este equipo que aunque va a
tener esos cambios en la parte delantera
no tiene dos laterales sobre todo la de
pérdidas vinculadas impresionante viene
a ser una muy buena eliminatoria va a
jugar los play-off con el rayo vallecano
su equipo en españa y es un equipo que
aunque en la delantera ya tiene cambios
y en los laterales desde atrás no se va
a poder armar también tenemos que hablar
también de venezuela porque la sobre la
situación de este país habló jose
peseiro que como hemos dicho se quedó
sin ocho jugadores por haberse
contagiado de kobe 19 ya antes del
comienzo del torneo escuchemos lo vamos
a hacer un partido muy posaba muy
presionado muy organizado tenemos ser
muy organizados y muy capaces del
sacrificio porque tenemos un partido en
que las fuerzas ante los partidos son
diferenciadas las puertas fuerzas están
diferenciadas dije dice jose peseiro el
que ha sido también uno de los que ha
rotado muchísimo porque llegó casi que
de repente una selección venezolana con
una estructura muy difícil de armar y
decir también esa rueda de prensa que ha
hecho muchos cambios y ahora los hace
casi que de manera forzada claro de
manera forzada
de las pcr le determinan a él el equipo
él también dijo y esto es muy claro que
no tiene un equipo para salir a
presionar a colombia sin duda
seguramente armará un bloque defensivo
interesante que le tape las salidas a
los jugadores que jueguen por bandas en
colombia vamos a ver también que
presenta reinaldo rueda entendiendo que
él también conoce las condiciones en las
que venezuela está entrenando así es y
antes de terminar vamos con más noticias
en diario de copas la selección uruguaya
llegó anoche a brasil hoy los charrúas
realizan su primer entrenamiento en el
territorio brasileño antes de su debut
este viernes ante la selección argentina
que viene de un empate contra chile
la federación danesa informó que
christian eriksen será operado para
implantarle un desfibrilador automático
después del desvanecimiento que el
jugador del inter sufrió el fin de
semana en el partido contra finlandia
el italiano locatelli también apartó las
botellas de refrescos en una rueda de
prensa como ya hizo cristiano ronaldo la
uefa emitió un comunicado en el que dice
haberle recordado de las elecciones de
las euros que de la eurocopa que los
patrocinadores son fundamentales
esta hora y antes de terminar vamos a
actualizar como ese parecido que tenemos
en juego minutos 62 de partido dinamarca
1 bélgica 1 estamos viendo un encuentro
que a priori bélgica parecía que estaba
muy fuerte pero está aguantando
dinamarca dinamarca sorprendió en el
primer tiempo anticipando muy bien
poniendo jugadores entre línea mañana lo
analizaremos desde partida estará como
siempre muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado un día más en tiro de copas y
a ustedes también muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros quédense porque más
mucho más en 324 324 puntocom
i